we are dangerously close to this point
nay we are already in it where we are
seeing police officers engage in illegal
activity we are seeing border patrol
officers engage in illegal activity and
this this issue of the tunnel under the
synagogue brings up a really important
question sooner or later it will be
impossible to answer what is the right
side of the law so again what we say is
you see a video of a guy and he's being
stopped by the police and he fights the
cops and the cops defend themselves and
the guy dies and then everyone's like oh
the cop's racist and I'm like dude if a
cop is stopping you don't fist fight him
you keep your mouth shut you put your
hands behind your back then you get in
touch with your lawyer and you win in
the system which we have built to to to
deal with these things but what happens
when the police are shutting down
churches
illegally and now the police are
basically kidnapping and threatening you
with violence without actual Authority